the forbes blockchain 50 list is our
fourth annual list of billion dollar
companies taking blockchain seriously we
initially created that billion dollar
requirement because we didn't want this
list to be about the coolest sexiest but
most unproven technology out there we
wanted this list to really reflect some
of the most mature
proven
and actually being used technology by
companies that as i like to say my mom
and dad know the first list in 2019 was
characterized by proofs of concept and
pilots these were big companies that the
world knew very well that had largely
set up skunk works in their basement
somewhere given them a little bit of
money and maybe got together a team of
five or 10 people to to test the
technology now fast forward four years
and those teams of four to five people
are now 400 to 500 people i think in
past years we've seen a real dominance
in the
hyperledger applications and they still
have a strong presence on the list but
we've seen two really notable changes
first is companies are getting
comfortable with public blockchains
so we're seeing more and more companies
build on the public version of ethereum
and other public blockchain applications
the other thing that's changed is china
china has a lot of that you know they
have companies that are sitting on the
boards at these nonprofit organizations
like hyperledger they are
learning they are exercising influence
um but perhaps more importantly they are
then taking what they learn and building
it in china we're seeing chinese
versions of a lot of these permissioned
blockchains being built and increasingly
we're even starting to see some of those
uh chinese native blockchain
applications going open source which is
kind of cool to see we have five social
networks on the list which is a record
and if you think about it they are kind
of the ultimate middleman like if i want
to sit down and have a conversation with
a friend of mine i i don't want to have
to rely on a middleman i don't really
even want to have to rely on a phone yet
alone an entire network so the fact that
this technology that was invented to let
people move value from one person to
another without a middleman is now being
used to let um so let people that are
previously using social networks um
connect uh is is really interesting one
thing to add there it is kind of a
defensive play similar to how banks
invested a lot to make sure that bitcoin
didn't cut them out of the global
financial strategy we're starting to see
social networks do some of the similar
investing the national basketball
association was sort of a surprise
addition to the list last year we would
not have expected to see a professional
sports team uh much less one of such
high profile getting into crypto they
basically made a play into the um
basketball cards space these were
previously provided by third-party
companies um that were leveraging the
mba brand and kids would go out and buy
these cards and trade them they're now
issuing their own trading cards they're
digital versions of these trading cards
using software provided by a third party
importantly
this is not just a gimmick it's not just
a splash in the pan
this is the second year on the list and
they have they sold 992 million dollars
almost a billion dollars worth of these
collectible moments adobe was a really
fun one i think they uh they sort of
epitomize uh how
the old guard the trusted institutions
are capitalizing on this essentially
what they did is they're letting their
content creators uh prove that they are
the content creators at the point of
creation if you create a work of art
using adobe software you can immediately
log it on
on the ethereum blockchain it will have
everything from who you are when you
created it what software you used um
what contributing works of art you used
to make sure that not only are you
getting credit for what you created um
but the the artwork that you used in
your creation is also being credited but
most importantly they're then letting
you take that turn it into an nft and
sell it on any number of nft exchanges
so the beast is actually another one of
my favorite applications on the list
this year they're a 278 year old auction
house they're better known for selling
picassos and van goghs and for
cryptocurrency um but not only or do
they now accept cryptocurrency as
payment for traditional auctions which
is kind of cool in its own right um but
they're they're getting into the nft
auction space they had their first big
auction this year was a 16.8 million
dollar deal but that's just a drop in
the bucket of the 100 million dollars
worth of nft sales that they did in
2021. walmart's kind of the epitome of
these companies that have gone from uh
making the list with pilots and proofs
of concept to very very mature offerings
walmart's one of the only companies on
the list to make it all four years and
they've come a long way from the early
days when we did a video showing the way
that you could track their food on a
blockchain and we were barely able to
put together a meal with four or five
items they've now grown to 1500 items
being tracked on a blockchain
the next to highlight is a beijing-based
baidu um which isn't necessarily the the
sexiest company here in the states um
though they do have a 15.5 billion
dollars sales and revenue
most americans haven't really crossed
paths with them directly but notably
they have 20 000 blockchain developers
working on various applications of
blockchain and they have actually
started to generate revenue from this
this is different from the early
blockchain applications that we're all
about saving money they were about
cutting corners removing unnecessary
middlemen but they weren't generating
revenue but i'd have shown that there is
a way forward that you can actually make
money by building these applications
and one of the things that i think
really stands out about baidu is many of
the chinese blockchain applications are
not open source id was one of the only
chinese blockchain companies that has
actually open sourced its blockchain
which is called superchain so you can
actually go and you can take a look
directly at the baidu blockchain code so
the next two companies that i want to
highlight are are related through a
person
that's block the payments company
formerly known as square and twitter uh
both of which were founded by jack
dorsey who has become one of the biggest
champions of bitcoin square rebranded in
2021 and they are now called block
shockingly honestly
uh they claim to have generated 9.8
billion dollars in revenue from bitcoin
sales in the 12 months ending september
2021. that is a huge amount of money um
and i think for any payments company
that is looking to seriously compete in
the future they have to at very least
consider blocks business model uh the
other half that though is is twitter uh
jack dorsey actually left twitter um
which was another sort of surprising
moment to focus all of his attention on
block but he didn't leave the vision for
blockchain and cryptocurrency behind i
think it's still really early days in
the use of nfts as profile images
but they've started to take the course
towards
ensuring that users are actually who
they say they are ncr is a newbie to the
list this year um and just so much fun
uh they're a
141 year old cash register company um
and that's maybe a little bit
oversimplifying it they've expanded into
atms they have 1.5 million locations
around the world
um but their their dna is in cash
registers this year they made a giant
move into the space they actually
purchased a boston-based startup called
liberty x uh that gave them access to 30
000 bitcoin atms uh but more than that
they purchased a company called
cardtronics that gave them access to
another 285 million atms this isn't just
about 141 year old company buying some
new machines that let you uh buy and
spend cryptocurrency they have actually
told us on the record that they plan to
convert all 1.5 million of their
existing locations into places where you
can buy and spend cryptocurrency
you